بالنسبة لسمير وأمل ، من
المؤلم أن يتصالحوا مع
فرارهم من شقتهم مع
لينا البالغة من العمر ثلاث سنوات ويوسف البالغ من العمر سبع سنوات
قبل ثوانٍ من
انهيار المبنى ، ووجدوا الآن
مأوى مؤقتًا في منزل واحد كريم في
اسطنبول.  مقيم يعيش في الخارج ولكن من
الصعب التغلب على صدمتهما ولا تزال
ذكريات الزلزال تطارد
هذه العائلة ، ولا يزال
أصدقاؤنا وأقاربنا
تحت الأنقاض ، وقد اختفت العائلة بأكملها ،
أخبرني يوسف أن أمي ليس لدي غرفة
ليس لديّ غرفة.  منزل لا ألعاب ولا أصدقاء
أريد العودة إلى المدرسة لينا
تبكي باستمرار إنها ابنتي الوحيدة
لقد غيرت كثيرًا من
فرص العثور على ناجين تحت
الأنقاض تتضاءل مع
مرور الوقت
ولكن في تركيا الأمل يستمر
مع المزيد من عمليات الإنقاذ المعجزة على
مدار الماضي  24 ساعة
ولكن مع مرور الأيام ، ينصب التركيز على
التحول لاستعادة الموتى
ومساعدة الأحياء ،
ولكن كما ترون هنا ، شكل هؤلاء المتطوعون
سلسلة بشرية لنقل
صناديق التبرعات هذه إلى هذه الشاحنة التي يتم تحميلها على
استعداد للمغادرة
يتجه مركز التوزيع هذا في إسطنبول
مباشرة إلى جنوب شرق تركيا الآن وفقًا
للمنسقين في هذا المركز ، هناك
حوالي 20000 متطوع يعملون على
مدار الساعة عبر مركزين هنا في
إسطنبول ، حيث عملوا خلال
الأسبوع الماضي على فرز آلاف
صناديق التبرعات الجاهزة.  ليتم إرسالها
إلى الأشخاص المتضررين من الزلزال ،
يقول المنسقون هنا إنهم بحاجة إلى مزيد من
الدعم ويخشون أن ينساهم
المجتمع الدولي ،
هل كنت خائفًا عندما حدث ذلك ،
نعم
مخيف خائف جدًا نعم ، وفي حين أن
الأعمال السخية قد تذهب إلى حد ما للمساعدة
بالنسبة لأولئك الذين فقدوا كل شيء ، فإن
إعادة البناء بدأت للتو في
اسطنبول ،
شكرًا لك